what's going on people today we're
breaking down the first episode of my
Academia season 6 in which president
Mike beats up a 100 year old man and the
war between heroes and villains finally
begins throughout this video I'll be
explaining why this war is even
happening in the first place the reason
all the heroes are in separate locations
and a couple small differences between
the anime and manga just before we get
into it though if you want me to
continue doing breakdowns for this
season then do let me know in the
comments down below and of course
subscribe so you don't miss future
videos like this okay so although the
new episode did begin with a brief recap
of season five I thought I'd do a quick
recap of my own just in case you didn't
fully understand what was going on for a
start last season the league of villains
faced off against another villain group
called The Meta Liberation Army and
after shigaraki defeated them the two
organizations merged into one this new
villain group is called the Paranormal
Liberation Front and they have gigantom
machia no moves and over a hundred
thousand soldiers working for them
including some Pro Heroes one of the
heroes serving them is Hawks who's been
undercover trying to find out
information and he discovered that the
villains planned to destroy every
everything in four months in response he
gave Endeavor a coded message to warning
about the upcoming attack while the hero
commission tried to prepare students for
War by forcing everyone to do
internships as the kids then got
stronger over the winter break the
police tried to discover more clues
about the villains by interrogating
kurugiri as it turns out kirigiri is a
highly Advanced nomu made from the
corpse of isawa's dead best friend and
thanks to the power of friendship erase
had briefly got him to talk in
particular he gave them a clue about a
hospital with that info then being part
of the hero commission who used coded
language to pass it on to Hawks
following that the season 6 premiere
shows us how Hawks was able to work out
the exact hospital kirigiri was
referring to and essentially it all
comes down to twice in the beginning of
this scene twice goes to him for advice
about the Paranormal Liberation France
ideology because as one of the
figureheads of the group it's something
that certain members are expecting him
to know during one of their previous
meetings he already mentioned that he
found the ideas confusing and it's why
we get this Expedition from Hawks where
he explains literally everything to
begin we learned that the entire
organization is split into four
different regiments which are each led
by the nine lieutenants these
lieutenants then have helpers who are in
charge of the different bases across
Japan meaning the villains have rarely
ever all in the same place that'll be
important later as it's a big factor in
why the heroes have to split up but
before we get to that The Liberation
ideology believes that all humans should
be free to use their quirks instead of
the current system where only one group
has that privilege to make these beliefs
more mainstream the plan is that in four
months time they'll launch a
simultaneous attack on all Japan's major
cities which will pretty much destroy
society's faith in Heroes back in the
Pro Hero Arc we saw how much trouble
Endeavor had trying to take down one
higher nomu so you can imagine how bad
things would be if multiple seeds were
being attacked at the same time by the
high ends the villains and The
Liberation Soldiers the most likely
outcome is that countless Heroes would
die and during the chaos trumpet and
redestra would be able to spread their
ideology as the leader of a political
party and the CEO of a company that
makes support items they distribute
weapons to the population and urge
civilians to rise up creating a lawless
Society that doesn't need Heroes Hawks
was able to gain this Intel since he was
specially trained by the commission from
a young age giving him the skills needed
to earn the trust of various Liberation
soldiers including twice himself as the
scene continues we see a previous moment
between the two in which Hawks was
teaching him about the Liberation Army
and it's here when we get the big reveal
at that stage in the timeline the number
two hero still hadn't gotten to meet
shigaraki and twice confesses it's
because he's undergoing a four-month
operation in the Kyoto mountains when
Hawks then combined the info about Kyoto
with the hint from shirakumo he was able
to work out that Jacob hospital is where
they needed to Target and pretty soon
the police sent someone there undercover
as a side note the name jakku is a
direct reference to the planet where Rey
grew up in Star Wars which shouldn't be
surprising considering that the author
of my hero is a well-known Star Wars
Fanboy anyway flashing forward by a
month the heroes have now put together
an intricate plan to take down the
Paranormal Liberation Front involving
all of the uh students originally class
1a had no idea they were being sent into
a war zone like this because at first
they were told it was just an expedition
addition relates to their work studies
however by this point it's pretty clear
they do now have some idea of what
they're up against as Deku and the rest
of them seem to understand the scale of
the operation with that said it's time
to break down what's happening in each
specific location and the best place to
start is jakku Hospital itself as we
established this is the place where
shigaraki is currently recovering and
the hospital was founded by all for
one's right-hand man Dr garaki the
surname goraki is clearly derived from
the name shigaraki which in case you
didn't know is afo's real last name in
addition to being tomorrow's adopted
name one intriguing detail about this
character is that he isn't just the
founder of the hospital but he's also
established several orphanages nurseries
and Care Homes giving him a steady
supply of young and old people to
conduct experiments on in fact in
chapter 186 of the manga we saw that one
of his nurseries was called hidimari
Kindergarten and it's where he stored
the higher nomu that fought against
Endeavor anyhow the reason the heroes
now know that garaki is a villain is
because there's a section of the
hospital that only he's allowed to go
into and their undercover Spa I was able
to snap this picture of a tiny nomu
standing next to the doctor that's why a
whole group of top heroes have arrived
in jakku to capture the doctor such as
wash izawa Endeavor Rock clock and tons
of other extras like Manuel and the
Pussycats the main obstacle they were
facing is that they need to arrest the
doctor in a way that doesn't alert the
other villains and so to accomplish this
the plan is to take down the entire
Liberation Army all at the same time
including their HQ which is 50 miles
away from jakku in that location you
have three of the top 10 Heroes on the
front lines as well as chainsaw man's
long-lost cousin and also there's a
handful of students like denki and
tokyami not to mention mushroom Garland
mod mad from class 1B like Momo goes on
to point out each of them have quirks
that are good for wide-ranging attacks
and so they're on the front lines to
take out as many villains as possible in
one go the rest of the kids without
wide-ranging attacks were stationed
further behind in the forest and the
idea is that hopefully they won't have
to get involved in the main battle now
one important thing worth highlighting
is that there's a very specific
motivation for the heroes to launch this
attack today thanks to hawks's detective
work he found out that the Liberation
Front lieutenants have a scheduled
meeting at HQ making this the best time
to get all of them at once the single
exception is of course shigaraki who's
in jakku and if we switch over to a
different part of the city Deku bakugou
and shotar injaku as well unlike
endeavor's group their main job isn't to
capture garaki or fight off any of the
nomu but rather their main priority is
helping with the evacuation meanwhile on
the streets the hero's sliding go was
arrested for being a traitor and this
was expected because Hawks are known for
a while that this guy was working for
the Liberation Army back inside the
hospital Endeavor and the Gang then
March in to confront garaki with the
doctor [ __ ] himself once he sees the
number one hero the anime then briefly
flashes over to a completely anime
original scene that takes place outside
natsuo's house in which fumi tells him
that she received a call from their dad
basically what happened is that endeavor
called her up to say that he wouldn't be
able to speak to them for a while
because of work and they both quickly
realized that something big must be
going on that sewer remarks that he
hopes things don't turn out like he did
in their Pro Hero walk because despite
Endeavor winning the bastard in the end
he did have a very hard time not dying
switching back to the hospital again as
garaki tries to run izawa easily trips
him up with The Binding cloth and uses
Erasure to reveal that old man does
actually have a quirk on the government
registry the doctor was officially
listed as being quarkless but here we
can see that he instantly aged up when
hit by Erasure indicating that his true
power is one that slows down the aging
process once it got erased by a Tsar his
true appearance was revealed to everyone
and in the mangere was confirmed later
on that he's at least 120 years old as
garaki then struggles to crawl away
detective tsukiuchi speculates that this
anti-asian Quirk is the same one wolf
once been using to survive since the
first generation this is a solid Theory
considering that the villains have
demonstrated the potential to replicate
quirks such as the Supreme generation
that seems to be possessed by every
black nomu In This Moment present Mike
then slaps the doctor's revenge for what
he did to shirakumo and while
questioning him some of the other Pro
Heroes start to evacuate the hospital
while one small piece of trivia is that
this guy here is takashita otherwise
known as the hero who used to go to
school with gentle criminal as we saw in
gentle's backstory the two of them used
to be in the same class but as they got
older takashita completely forgot who
gentle was triggering him so badly that
he became a villain so that his name
could be remembered by Future
Generations in any case with isawa
capturing garaki the animator takes us
to Police Headquarters which is acting
like a control center to coordinate this
whole operation this scene is another
anime original moment and it's these
police officers who mention what maker
is up to the impatient number five hero
surged ahead of everyone else to enter
the hospital morgue which is the only
way to access garaki's secret area
leaping through the hallway like a
rabbit she's then confronted by a horde
of mid-level nomu and this is when we
get the big reveal of the episode as it
turns out the Dr garaki they arrested
was actually a clone made from twice's
Quirk and the real version of the doctor
has been inside his secret lab the
entire time although it wasn't
explicitly made clear in the anime
version in the manga there were TV
screens inside this I'm showing him
everything that had been happening and
it's why in response he sent no moves to
store the heroes out of nowhere a giant
whale with a similar Quirk to gang
Walker then burst out of the ground and
inside his mouth is another nomu that
has muscly tentacle arms with drills on
the end these two are said to destroy
the fake Dr garaki presumably so that
the heroes don't capture him and before
the Clone melts away he makes the
observation that Erasure wasn't able to
destroy the double ordinarily you might
expect that because isawa can erase
quirks he should be able to erase a
clone but in reality it just treats the
Clones like actual people following that
more mid-level nomu burst out into the
hospital Reception Area while at the
same time Mirko Rampages through the
morgue this brief clip where she
decapitates The Gnome who really helps
bring to life just how unbelievably fast
and Powerful she is and while that's
going on the real garaki was reluctantly
making plans to run away the reason I
say it's reluctant is because the
doctor's secret lab is basically his
life's work and if he abandons it he
knows that the heroes will likely
destroy everything on the walls you
literally have thousands of quarks
stored in each of these jars and it goes
without saying that these must have been
harvested from innocent people over a
super long period of time in addition to
that there are also multiple higher
gnomus recovering in their tanks so From
garaki's perspective he doesn't want to
leave all that behind that being said he
ultimately doesn't have a choice but to
save just himself in shigaraki and in
order to escape he needs to use the
warping Quirk this Quirk is possessed by
both all for one and Johnny the nomu and
it's the only way the doctor can leave
without having to go through the heroes
however just as he gives Johnny the
order to teleport them away Mirko breaks
down this huge Metal tour with a single
kick shattering hundreds of quirks and
crushing Johnny in the process the
episode then comes to an end with her
asking Dr garaki if he's the real
version and overall I'd personally give
this episode a 9 out of 10. it was great
to start the season by just getting
straight into the main plot rather than
having a filler episode like we usually
do and it had a lot of suspense a lot of
excitement several moments that were
done a lot better than they looked on
paper including the moment when graki
melted away and the moment when twice
was talking about sanctum so yeah
overall I think it was really great
definitely an improvement on the things
we were seeing in season five anyway
that's pretty much everything I wanted
to say about the season premiere but let
me know in the comments what you thought
of the episode and also if you want to
see more breakdowns like this right now
I'm not sure whether I want to do full
episode breakdowns or if I want to do
just videos explaining certain things in
the episode it would be good to get your
guys opinion on that so that I know what
to do going forward and uh yeah until
the next one peace out